listen I want to start with congrats on
making one of the best films I've seen
this year I love this movie
um and I have a lot of questions but I
like throwing a curveball to start
things off uh if someone is actually
never seen anything that either of you
have done before what is the first thing
you want them watching and why I've had
three experiences no four experiences I
think ta being top of the list and then
I played Blanche Dubois on stage
directed by levolman which was kind of
life-changing and um
most of them have been on stage actually
and working with the other Todd
field on playing Bob Dylan you know
these these asks that that the directors
make of you that you can't even imagine
what the experience is going to be but I
I don't not just because we're here
talking about it but I would have to say
tar because my experience as a you know
before I was even involved in in the the
project of reading the script is I'd
never read anything like it and I think
the film that Todd has made is unlike
any other film that I've ever seen what
about you
wow
um
uh in the third grade
in eighth grade I had this video project
um no I would I I would I feel the same
I I don't I haven't uh I haven't had
this kind of collaboration
um and and
yeah this has been like any um
anything I've ever been involved in
before uh I would say tar
um you know I don't I've never gone back
and looked at any films that I've ever
worked on in any capacity
um uh and it's been a very long time
since I've made a film but I even so I
can tell you
um with the straight face it would be
tar yeah I I again I can't say enough
positive things um Todd I read that you
were writing this with Kate in mind at
what point did you find out Kate that he
was writing this and what would have
honestly happened had she said no just
right now
I didn't I didn't fortunately I didn't
know that
um when we were working together there
was so much to do and the conversation
was so rich that it was literally like
the gate opened and we just we just went
for it yeah so we didn't I know I just
right now is that you're being sincere
no today I mean today yeah no no no no I
mean yes I wrote it I didn't write it
with Kate in mind I wrote it for Kate I
didn't tell her I was writing it Kate
and I had uh had met uh about uh 10
years ago to talk about a project that
um a script that um had been working on
with Joe Didion for a while
um and uh that film didn't come together
um and um I never thought of of an actor
before uh writing uh but I knew based on
that meeting
um outside of Kate's uh work as an
artist just out of that meeting now that
conversation that's that I was
that was a kind of collaboration I was
really desperate to have and um and um
and and that's why in answer to your
question you know um what would you have
people look at I would this is probably
um uh this was this was an extraordinary
conversation to have with with an artist
like Kate and um uh and it would and it
was a
you know it was a it was a conversation
that had to do about us asking questions
yeah we were we were each asking
questions about very very similar things
and uh
and trying to figure out if there was an
intelligent way to answer those those
questions
um
so um yeah so that's a long digressive
way of saying yes I wrote it for for
Kate and had she not done it yes I
wouldn't have made the film there are so
many scenes in this movie that I would
like to dissect with the two of you
because they're so striking and
incredible but one sequence in
particular was um and this is not
earlier in the film is where you are
teaching the students and it's a long if
I remember correctly it's a Warner where
the camera oh yeah
where the camera is following your
performance going to different positions
you are delivering an incredible amount
of dialogue that is very complicated can
you both talk a little bit about pulling
off that scene because as I was watching
it I just couldn't believe what I was
seeing on screen well hopefully you're
not aware that it's a one or I mean
there's all kinds of winners there's
winners that are really bravaro you know
kind of uh so like Good Fellas going
into the Copa or you know the beginning
of Boogie Nights or or rope or or Touch
of Evil kind of a player or the player
you know and then there's ones like uh
at the beginning of like code unknown
you know where you're about halfway
through until you realize it's a winner
and it wasn't that it had to be a Warner
uh it was you know
um
I it was important that we always feel
like we're with her and and that we and
that we feel like we're with her
at every possible moment and the idea of
uh
what needs to be what needs to be
accomplished or what what one would hope
would be accomplished in the execution
of that scene the idea of giving anyone
any control other than
Kate uh seemed antithetical to what that
scene was about so
um
you know there was a certain point where
I said to Florian Hofmeister our
cinematographer I said we were out
scouting last summer and I said it has
to be a Warner
um but I don't know how to do it we
can't technically it's almost impossible
we can't do it with the Steadicam we
can't do it with a crane we can't do
with all these things and so we started
to talk about a way that we might be
able to do it
um but the first thing was I had to
convince Kate that this is a good idea
um and I remember we pulled over on the
side of the road and I called her up and
then which whenever Todd delivers bad
news he always says okay here's the
thing
here's the thing I go okay what is it
well no but but but Kate said
immediately but she didn't even like not
even one second I said we have to do it
as a winner and said well you can't do
it as one I said why she says well
because the legs she has to see the leg
and I said no no we can figure out how
to get to the lake
so so that was it so it was it it was we
we rehearsed uh
Kate and I went in alone and we we
blocked that scene together
um and then we brought the crew in and
we and we blocked it for the crew and
adjusted and then we shot it for two
full days
um and um and uh because we'd get we'd
get through it I think the first time we
did it we got all the way through and we
were all and then something happened
with the mechanics of the camera it was
no one's fault and it just flipped off
so we couldn't well yeah it may have
been someone's fault but no but yeah the
very first take actually um was perfect
until the very last moment and then we
spent sort of two days sort of chasing
that um but um uh but that's a it it's
it's a again it's a scene where we have
to it was important that that she's in
control of that entire scene and it and
it's a scene that um
was sort of the the beginning of the
script for me was that scene uh that's
the first scene that I wrote and I wrote
it and rewrote it for probably four
months and it was a scene
um you know I'm always haunted by that
question when somebody says to you if
you if you could go back and talk to
your younger self what would you say
and and for me that's that's what that
scene is about it's about this character
who's at a very particular point in her
life where she's done a lot of
experimenting and she's done a lot she's
pushed the boundaries and she's at a
very kind of conservative place at this
point in her life but if you were
talking to her 24 year old self or 25
year old self what would she what would
she say and
um and very much this character of Max
you know could have been Lydia there by
the grace of God go I at 25 when she
graduated from Harvard wanting to do the
same thing that she's telling Max not to
do you know doing experimental music
doing a tonal music that you know maybe
poo pooing the sort of German austro
Canon but that's not where she is now
you know um uh
so it it's a um
you know it there's a there's a real
Reckoning with this character you know
um is she she makes forward value and
attempts to try to bring him on side and
then she and then she she can't keep her
powdered dry anymore you know um and and
that's a real failure for her she sees
that as a real defeat
um I think uh I mean you probably have
other feelings about him yeah oh I got
to stop I was gonna see if you had
anything else but I just want to thank
you so much nothing I have nothing yeah
I'm so sorry
it was very long no no no no no no no no
I just again I just want to say thank
you so much for making the movie it's
incredible I wish you guys nothing but
the best thank you very much I
appreciate it